[музика]
вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми
Європа У фокусі раді що ви приєднались
до нас погода в Європі стає все більш
екстремальною Цього літа ми стали
свідками спеки посухи та лісових пожеж у
деяких регіонах У той час як інші
пережили проливні дощі та повені
балканська країна Словенія бореться з
наслідками найсильнішого за кілька
десятиліть стихійного лиха
проливні дощі спричинили сильні повені
та суви ґрунту внаслідок чого кілька
річок вийшли з берегів тисячі людей були
змушені евакуюватися зі своїх домівок
після найсильніших повеней в історії
країни
основні автомобільні та залізничні шляхи
були перекриті а кілька сіл повністю
відрізані від решти світу
прем'єр-міністра Словенії заявив що дві
третини країни постраждали від раптових
повеней щоб запобігти таким стихійним
лихам у майбутньому потрібно більше дам
як наприклад у любляні
Бенедикт поточнік живе в цьому красивому
горбистому регіоні мальовничому але
також вразливому до стихійних лих
будинки поглинуті річками мости
зруйновані водою
словенський столяр Бенедикт поточнік не
знає коли і як він зможе знову працювати
після того як раптові повені охопили дві
третини його країни
та урата вода виламала ці двері і
затопила всю майстерню усі мої столярні
верстати були всередині і все це тепер
знищено
ми витратили 30 років свого життя щоб
побудувати це
за дві години все це зникло
і досі бруд уламки та мул вкривають
відрізане від світу місто чорна на
корошки
Бенедикт запрошує нас у свій родинний
дім тут немає Ані води Ані світла
вода дійшла аж сюди
вона була скрізь
зараз тут працюють пожежники вони
Відмінно виконують свою роботу
інші також долучаються до допомоги
сусіди відрами зливають бруд
солдати відкопують будинки з підмолу
жахливо наскільки сильною може бути
природа ми щасливі що можемо виконувати
свій обов'язок це все що має значення і
все що ми можемо зробити
сила природи тут проявляється в повній
мірі але далеко від зони затоплення
також проявляється сила словенської
солідарності
за годину їзди у веленіє Червоний Хрест
Був завалений пожертвам
робочі рукавички рукавички для
прибирання Нам вдалося зібрати досить
багато а також інструменти
[музика]
У нас багато віників і лопат їх
розкуповують магазинах і люди приїжджали
з усієї Словенії щоб привести їх сюди і
вони продовжують приїжджати приносять
їжу воду у пляшках рушники та інші речі
першої необхідності
майже у кожного є постраждалі серед
друзів чи родичів
ми маленька країна
кожна копійка допомагає Я думаю що ми
впораємося з цим
далі на південь у любляні
інженери-гіротехніки думають про ширшу
картину їхні моделі точно передбачали де
відбудеться повінь але не її
інтенсивність тепер Кліматичні зміни
змінюють очікування
Ми не можемо жити далі думаю що це
неповториться
це станеться знову І ми маємо бути
готовими це означає що потрібно будувати
більше захисних споруд від повеней
подібних до цієї що в любляні вона була
збудована після повені у 2010 році і
допомогла вберегти район від катастрофи
того разу прімо з бановець впевнений що
буде створено більше інфраструктури ця
катастрофа привернула увагу але він каже
що деяким громадам можливо доведеться
переїхати і з найбільш ризикованих
регіонів назавжди
це один з найскладніших компонентів
переїзд
недооцінюються скільки болю Це може
викликати у людей які змушені переїхати
але їм доведеться переїхати
у черні жителі досі не можуть його
втатись президентка Словенії приїхала
аби висловити їм підтримку
словенський уряд зараз робить усе
можливе за допомогою НАТО та
Європейського союзу
можу вас запевнити що ніхто не
залишиться без уваги ніхто не залишиться
без даху над головою але на відбудову за
даними які я маю на сьогоднішній день
підуть на місяці а роки
Бенедикт Каже що йому нестерпно думати
про майбутнє в якому повені можуть стати
частішими
Ми якось упораємося
поки що він продовжуватиме прибирати
шукаючи Надії Серед гір багнюки
в Іспанії стоїть Така спека що навіть
іспанці не витримують її
однак цю ситуацію можна обернути на
користь
Іспанія прагне Використовувати сонячну
енергію і для цього уже встановлюють
фотоелектричні станції у найбільш
сонячних регіонах країни прямо на порозі
станції Анхель етеровіч який не лише
роздратований цією ситуацією але й
стурбований потенційними змінами
ландшафту андалус і на півдні Іспанії Це
конфлікт який стосується багатьох людей
у цій частині країни
Анхель Таро від живе в одному із
найсонячніших районів Іспанії зі своєю
дружиною та кіньми але він занепокоєний
адже саме це сонце привернуло
промисловість до міста Та берназ що вам
далось їй поруч із його маєтком або
фінкою нещодавно побудували величезну
сонячну електростанцію
Ми переїхали і з міста у сільську
місцевість і тепер навколо нас будують
ці сонячні електростанції справжні
індустріальні зони прямо біля нашого
будинку
і планується ще більше Іспанія хоче
отримувати зелену енергію і з рясного
сонячного світла
Це добре для клімату але загрожує планам
анхеля він хоче відкрити тут центр
іпотерапії
це має бути гарне місце де можна приємно
провести день
але якщо люди не захочуть приїздити
доведеться відмовитися від нашого
проєкту
[музика]
для інших сонячні батареї уособлюють
економічне зростання після того як
туризм занепав під час пандемії ковідмер
Хосе Діаз радий кожному вкладеному
центру
багато хто Втратив роботу всі важкі часи
тепер завдяки цим будівельним проєктам
дехто зміг повернутися на ринок праці
оливкові Гаї вирубують щоб звільнити
місце для сонячних електростанцій деякі
фермери скористалися можливістю здати в
оренду або продати свою землю
енергетичним компаніям Ніколай хвойдан
передав частину своєї землі тому що вода
стає все більш дефіцитною і дорогою
зрошення більше не окупається
без води тут нічого не росте
тому ми намагаємося отримати хоч щось
від нашої землі
понад 200 іспанських громадян б'ють на
сполохи борються проти полів сонячних
панелей
Луїс болоньo та інші побоюються що
Іспанія стане постачальником
електроенергії для Європи за рахунок
народу
якщо тут побудують величезні сонячні
електростанції з усіма їхніми
екологічними та соціальними наслідками
це в основному забезпечують економічне
зростання та робочі місця деінде але не
тут
це несправедливо Іспанію колонізують і
експлуатують
є інші шляхи наприклад вальмо-сіті що за
50 кілометрів звідси Це село побудувало
фотоелектричну станцію на даху свого
маленького театру щоб виробляти власну
електроенергію мер Франціско Гарсія з
гордістю розповідає про створення
енергетичної спільноти за підтримку
фонду регіонального розвитку ЄС
що ми тут виробляємо залишиться в нашій
громаді Ми не хочемо продавати нашу
енергію великим компаніям
Ми хочемо мати доступно нишкідливо для
клімату електроенергії для всіх наших
громадян
наразі ця електростанція забезпечує
електроенергію 21 домогосподарство і
очікується що до неї приєднаються
підприємства та ресторани
але Луїс болоньo каже що Іспанія занадто
багато уваги приділяє великомасштабним
проектам держава дає компаніям що
виробляють сонячні батареї свободу дій
замість того щоб гарантувати що вони
будуватимуть лише на занедбаних
промислових ділянках такої ж потужності
можна досягти не руйнуючи довкілля
але немає ніякого планування
сонячні батареї там де коли стояли
дерева любитель коней Анхель етаровіч
досі не може цього зрозуміти
Ми не можемо знищувати довкілля задля
його ж захисту це безглуздо кіно
термінал
[музика]
на думку анхеля нестримне зростання
сонячних полів суперечить їхньому
призначенню він сподівається що майбутні
проекти будуть більше екологічними як
наприклад У сусідньому альма-сіті щоб
Зелена електроенергія була дійсно
зеленою
відколи криза вартості життя та інфляція
вразили Великобританію розрив між
багатими і бідними став ще більш
помітним У той час як заможна верхівка
суспільства насолоджується життям
мільйони людей ледве можуть дозволити
собі найнеобхідніше гайсинг Вотсон
мільйонер і готовий добровільно платити
більше податків щоб допомогти тим хто
цього потребує однак зробити це не так
просто як може здатися
ніде у Західній Європі нерівність між
багатими і бідними не проявляється так
сильно як у Великій Британії
[музика]
це можна побачити навіть види личного
девоні на кордоні з корнулом
гайсинкс Вотсон входить до 10 000
найбагатших людей Факт який він зовсім
не цінує після короткої кар'єри
корпоративного консультанта у Лондоні та
нью-йорку зараз він експериментує з
вирощуванням органічних овочів на фермі
своїх батьків
сінг Вотсон повернувся до землі коли
зрозумів що за гроші щастя не купиш
тепер він заробляє більше ніж будь-коли
мріяв
компанія ріверфорд органікс Що налічує
понад сотню працівників одна з
найбільших органічних ферм Великої
Британії за останні кілька років він
передав стовідсоткове право власності
своїм працівникам За відносно низьку
ціну зараз Він виконує лише роль
наставника
[музика]
Гадаю я завжди хотів використовувати
бізнес щоб змінювати світ
я хотів змінити світ так що він був
більш схожий на такий в якому я хотів би
жити світ в якому не панували б
нерівність і жадібність
зростаюча бідність навколо обурює його
нинішній Уряд не робить нічого щоб
допомогти а все більше людей потерпають
від інфляції та зростання відсоткових
ставок він сам був би ради платити
набагато більше податків щоб змінити цю
ситуацію
у своєму офісі Він показує нам відкритий
лист які написав спільно із Сорока
іншими мільйонерами прем'єр-міністру
Великої Британії Річчі сунаку вони
пишуть якби податки для
мультимільйонерів були підвищені лише на
один відсоток Це дало б щорічний приріст
доходів еквівалентний приблизно 60
мільярдів євро патріотичний мільйонер
Великобританії запросили ріші сунака
приєднатися до нас 19 травня щоб
закликати до більш справедливої
податкової системи але він як не дивно
чомусь відмовився
насправді прем'єр-міністр і його партія
виступають категорично проти збільшення
податків взагалі і особливо проти
будь-якого виду податку на багатство
пані спікери Ні я не вважаю що зараз
Настав час для податку на багатство і
ніколи не настане час для нього Настав
час визнати виклик з яким ми стикаємося
Але така позиція не означає що Торі - це
партія лише багатих як пояснює один із
їхніх депутатів що ж гроші в наш час
дуже мобільні тому якщо ми будемо
посилати неправильні сигнали то гроші
будуть витікати з країни тоді як
насправді ми хочемо щоб гроші надходили
в країну щоб вони інвестувалися в
реальну економіку не тільки у власність
але й підприємства які створюють робочі
місця на своїй фермі гайсинг Вотсон
вважає такі висновки абсолютною
нісенітницею Я маю на увазі що це просто
неправда тобто просто Подивіться на те
що відбувалося протягом останніх десяти
років Як люди можуть продовжувати це
говорити бідні стають біднішими багаті
стають багатшими немає ніякого
просочування вниз є просочування вгору Я
просто не можу повірити що ми чуємо цей
аргумент знову і знову коли насправді
він не має під собою жодного фактичного
підґрунтя наразі понад два мільйони
британців покладаються на продовольчі
банки щоб вижити
Цей банк регулярно отримує пожертвування
фруктів та овочів і сперми вотсона
за останні 8 місяців Він роздав Понад
мільйон порцій їжі
дедалі частіше звичайні сім'ї потребують
допомоги щоб мати змогу прогодувати
своїх дітей
пакунки роздають Людям яких місто
визначило як малозабезпечених таким як
Лео та його партнерка мас
вона втратила роботу після перенесеної
операції їй було важко прогодувати
чотирьох дітей
до того як вони дізналися про
продовольчий банк Вони часто їли лише
один раз на день не лише у мене так я
маю друзів з дітьми які опинилися в
такому становищі Мій брат в такій самій
ситуації він втратив роботу у нього була
іпотека І знаєте тепер Він мусить
продати свій будинок Він втрачає десятки
тисяч у нього будуть великі борги і нам
досі важко знаєте адже ми все ще маємо
отримувати їжу бувають моменти коли я
відчуваю що цього місяця у мене все
добре тому що мені не треба ні в кого
просити їжу
але потім все одно доводиться це робити
І це боляче знаєте ніби гордість чи що
там Ну не знаю твоя гідність Ну ти
просто почуваєшся дуже приниженим
поки що він зводить кінці з кінцями і
сподіваються що ніхто не помітить
Можливо все почне змінюватися на краще
каже він нам але такі люди як Гайсин
квотсон які краще поінформовані не мають
особливої Надії що це станеться
найближчим часом а уряд продовжує
наполягати на тому що все йде як по
маслу у довгостроковій перспективі самі
основи британської демократії можуть
опинитися під загрозою
вони роблять серйозну помилку Я дійсно
хвилююся щодо розриву суспільного
договору і втрати інвестиції людей в
суспільство
що кінцем У підсумку призведе до
насильства і революції що на мою думку
Нікому не потрібно
але я відчуваю що це наближається
він не бачить нестачі в ідеях для
вирішення цих проблем але яка від них
користь якщо для них просто немає
політичної волі
Венеція безсумнівно найо улюбленіша
італійське місто серед туристів однак
воно стало настільки переповненим що
людям часто доводиться протискатися
крізь вузькі вулички що безперечно
ускладнює життя місцевому населення
насправді в Старому центрі міста
залишилося дуже мало місцевих жителів і
ці хто досі живе там незадоволені що
Шарм їхнього міста втрачається
Джованні Леоне хоче щоб його місці було
Менше туристів і активно виступає за це
але це завдання геть не з легких
танцювати це прекрасна річ можна
танцювати щоб висловити щастя або любов
можна танцювати швидко або повільно
можна танцювати наодинці або з друзями
але чи можна танцювати сидячи це можливо
бельгійська танцівниця Іріс муки шимана
стала перша відкривачкою цією унікальної
форми танців її хореографія зосереджена
на подоланні обмежень у буквальному
сенсі цього слова
[музика]
швидко і стильно проноситься потан сполу
цей танець аж ніяк не назвеш рутиною це
називається цикло дамс один партнер на
ногах а другий на візку як наприклад
інструкторка з багаторічним стажем і ріс
мукашімана
Ось за що я люблю циклоданс він об'єднує
людей
більше немає бар'єру між людиною на
візку і людиною без нього
мені так добре що на кілька хвилин
циклон з дозволяє мені забути про свою
інвалідність
тут у лувен ланев Бельгія і ріс готує
своїх учнів до особливого виступу вони
ретельно працюють над хореографією та
вдосконалюють Темп
але для цих танцюристів заняття - це
набагато більше ніж вивчення рухів це
музика дружба та обмін досвідом я не
можу танцювати без партнерки а вона не
може танцювати без мене
я наче птах що летить
візок дає мені можливість літати
[музика]
сьогодні і ліс заклопота на працююча
мама але в дитинстві в руанзі вона
перехворіла на поліомієліт і втратила
здатність ходити потім почалася війна
Яка переросла у геноцид багато членів її
сім'ї загинули
Іріс вижала завдяки крихітному шансу на
порятунок коли її дитячу лікарню
евакуювали бельгійські миротворці
персонал лікарні сказав Нам сховатися
під ковдрою не рухатися
це було просто ми були такі налякані
для цього ми чули як люди говорили Вони
біжать Вони біжать вони планували прийти
і вбити нас
потім вона росла у бельгійській
прийомній родині
я була повністю розгубленою коли вперше
приїхала до Бельгії
Я навіть не знала як привітатися нічого
Жодного слова французькою
[музика]
Хоча і різне забуває темних сторінок
свого минулого вона сповнена рішучості
продовжувати рухатись уперед саме тому
12 років тому Вона заснувала тут у
Бельгії власну школу танців щоб
змінювати життя інших людей і за її
словами тому що Шоумастгоуон до
місцевого громадського центру прибувають
глядачі вистава на підтримку місцевої
благодійної організації і партнер Іріс
допомагає організаторам усе підготувати
уже не вперше він відчуває гордість за
Іріс
це в ній самій Є в ній щось таке що
тягне до неї людей що об'єднує їх за
лаштунками в гримерці артисти готуються
[музика]
до видостані штрихи у своєму костюмі але
її місія тут тільки починається Я хочу
зруйнувати бар'єри і показати що
незалежно від того є у вас інвалідність
чи ні ви можете досягати успіху і
насолоджуватися танцем
[музика]
Ірі сподівається що виступаючи на сцені
вона допоможе іншим розправити крила
А на сьогодні це все Бережіть себе і до
зустрічі за тиждень у новому випуску
Європа У фокусі
[музика]